Hey, this is Joshua with The Verge,...
...and we are looking at and holding the new iPad Mini.
It is incredibly small.
You can actually see, as a comparison with the original iPad or the new iPad,...
...very big difference in size.
It's obviously a more of a one-handed device for reading.
I'll be taking it to bed with me romantically.
And as you could see, it's extremely thin, 7.2 millimeters,...
...and it's very light, 0.68 pounds.
The screen is a 7.9 inch, 1024 by 768 display,...
...but at the smaller size, the resolution looks higher...
...than if you look at an iPad 2 in comparison.
This definitely looks a lot tighter as far as pixel density is concerned.
It does feel incredibly light in the hand.
This version that I'm holding has an LTE option,...
...and as I mentioned in my write-up,...
...the build quality of this is, you know, you expect from Apple a great build quality,...
...but in comparison to other 7-inch tablets on the market,...
...it's night and day.
Compared to something like the Nexus 7,...
...this just feels like a really high-end piece of technology.
You see here speakers on the bottom, Lightning connector...
...and it is exactly what you expect, the smaller iPad.
329 is the starting price for 16 gig,...
...and it goes up from there depending what kind of storage...
...and whether or not you're adding wireless options,...
...cellular options.
So, that's a quick look at the Mini,...
...and we'll have more information and more photos and more video coming soon.